In biological systems is very important
to be able to
phosphorylate glucose.
Let's start with the glucose molecule
and phosphorylate it. This is important because
once we have that phosphate group -
Let me put the charge on it.
Once we add this phosphate group
or if we have that negative charge
in glucose-6-phosphate,
it becomes much harder for him to leave the cage.
A cell wants to have as many molecules of glucose as possible.
When glucose is not loaded,
it can pass through the cell membrane,
but once it is phosphorylated,
will remain in the cage.
Additionally, glucose-6-phosphate
is very important for
a whole sequence of processes in the cells.
Unfortunately, the reaction
of phosphorylation of glucose
requires energy. It is endogenous
and will not go spontaneously.
The value of delta G for this reaction is positive.
She is
endergonic.
You can guess what we will need,
to be able to run.
We will have to use the cell's energy currency,
our good friend ATF.
For the glucose phosphorylation reaction to occur, you need to
combined with a reaction that we can look at
such as hydrolysis of ATP,
although we will not have a precise molecule of water
in the mechanism,
but functionally the reaction is hydrolysis of ATP
to ADP and a phosphate group.
ATP hydrolysis is energy-efficient,
it is exergonic,
will run spontaneously
under the right conditions.
I will not run constantly
in the cell solution,
it needs a little activating energy or enzyme,
which will lower the activating energy,
but overall the reaction is exogenous.
We can combine these two reactions.
When we combine them,
when we combine the two reactions,
we have ATP,
ATP plus glucose,
plus glucose,
who respond.
We also use an enzyme,
the generic term for which is hexokinase,
it helps the reaction by reducing the activating energy.
We'll get
glucose-6-phosphate
and ADP.
And ADP.
A-D-F.
What is the value of delta G for this reaction?
We can look at the reaction
as a combination of two reactions,
so we can roughly say,
that we will collect the values ​​of delta G.
If we collect the delta G values,
we will get -
If we collect this negative value of delta G
of the exergy reaction and this positive value,
we will have -30.5 plus 13.8,
which is -16.7 kJ / mol
kJ / mol.
Therefore, this combination of reactions will be exogenous.
Not so exergic as hydrolysis,
because we will use some of its energy,
but it can go spontaneously
especially if we lower the activating energy enough.
Now let's look at the mechanism,
in which it flows.
If we do not have an enzyme,
the mechanism of reaction is as follows,
we have
free electron pair here,
in this hydroxyl group
and it must participate in a nucleophilic response
with this phosphor atom here.
But it will be very difficult without an enzyme.
The reaction will have a very high activating energy,
because all these negative charges
oxygen atoms will interfere.
You can guess that the electrons do not
love the negative charges,
they are repelled by negative charges.
That is why we will need an enzyme,
to help the reaction
and to lower the activating energy in order for the reaction to begin.
The enzyme virtually removes these electrons from the reaction path.
The enzyme or the general term
for the enzymes with this function - hexokinase.
Hexokinase, I'll write it down.
Hexokinase.
Hexokinase "delivers" ions,
we can imagine that they
keep these electrons "busy".
More specifically, the enzyme has a magnesium ion,
magnesium ion
right here,
which is linked to the rest of the hexokinase.
Remember, all this happens in three dimensions.
We can say that hexokinase is wrapped around molecules,
to "dispel" these electrons,
there are other ions in the hexokinase,
who hold these electrons "busy".
Other positive ions "distract" these electrons.
So these electrons can slip
and to carry out the nucleophilic reaction.
Remember, the enzymes are
proteins.
I will write it in the same color that I wrote hexokinase.
Enzymes are these complex protein structures
right here.
We can have magnesium ion,
I will color it in purple.
Right here and maybe the glucose molecule -
the glucose molecule binds here,
then we have ATP,
he connects here.
Obviously simple
I give an example,
not everything is happening in reality.
But in essence, the enzyme is wrapped around the molecules with its positive charges,
manages to pull the electrons aside
and to promote the nucleophilic response,
which has to be accomplished.
Therefore, this link here,
between this oxygen and this phosphorus,
will be,
this link will be here.
When this happens,
these two electrons can be taken from
this oxygen.
This oxygen here,
he will now have a negative charge.
That's what we got
glucose-6-phosphate and ADP.
And ADP.
This reaction is energy-efficient,
it is exergonic.
It will happen,
provided that we have the enzyme,
which "distracts" these electrons
and reduces the activating energy.
I know what you think,
we had hydrogen here,
this hydrogen must still be here,
then another water molecule may come
and grab the proton, the water proton.
And so we get it again
glucose-6-phosphate.
I hope this video clarified you
how combinations of reactions,
and why ATP is actually useful.
When I was studying for the ATF I first thought,
well,
he really wants to get rid of it
of this phosphate group, it is energy efficient,
but how to use this,
to trigger other processes to happen
something in the system,
which may not be energy-efficient.
I hope that this video explained to you how this is happening,
as well as the importance of enzymes
for this reaction.